tomamos esta decisión en una consulta
cercana con aliados y socios en todo el
mundo particularmente en europa
porque una respuesta unida a la agresión
de putin ha sido mi enfoque personal
que toda la otan y que toda la unión
europea que todos estos aliados estén
completamente unidos estamos avanzando
con este evento entendiendo que muchos
aliados europeos y socios pueden no
estar en una posición de unirse a
nosotros eeuu produce mucho más petróleo
domésticamente que todos los países
europeos combinados de hecho somos un
gran exportador de energía podemos tomar
este paso cuando otros no pueden
préstamos trabajando de cerca con europa
y nuestros socios para desarrollar una
estrategia a largo plazo para reducir su
dependencia sobre energía rusa también
nuestros equipos están discutiendo cómo
hacer que esto suceda y hoy seguimos
unidos unidos
en este propósito de mantener la presión
sobre putin y su maquinaria de guerra
es un paso que estamos tomando para
infligir mayor daño
pero habrá un costo también en eeuu dije
que sería claro que por eso ni desde
principio y cuando dije esto lo primero
es dije que defender la libertad va a
costar nos va a costar a nosotros
también en los eeuu
republicanos y demócratas se entienden
los republicanos y los demócratas saben
que tenemos que hacer esto durante la
última semana hablé con el presidente de
selenski varias veces para saber de él
que pensaba en la situación en el
terreno seguir consultando con nuestros
aliados europeos para nuestro respaldo
hacia el pueblo ucraniano hasta ahora
hemos brindado más de 1000 millones de
dólares en asistencia de seguridad de
ucrania
cargamentos de armas defensivas están
llegando a ucrania cada día por parte de
eeuu y nosotros los eeuu estamos
coordinando la entrega de ayuda similar
por parte de nuestros aliados alemania
finlandia holanda
estamos trabajando en esto también
estamos brindando ayuda humanitaria para
el pueblo ucraniano
tanto a los que están en ucrania como a
los que han huido a la seguridad de un
país vecino
trabajamos con organizaciones monetarias
para servir a
decenas de miles de toneladas de comida
y agua en ucrania y hay mucho más en
curso en camino durante el fin de semana
el secretario blinken a visitar la
frontera la frontera entre polonia y
ucrania y moldavia a ver cómo era la
situación de primera mano y que nos
reportará el general milk y presidente
del departamento conjunto del
departamento de estado también estuvo en
un encuentro con sus contrapartes y
aliados en la otan del flanco oeste para
reafirmarle esos países que están en la
frontera con rusia que mantendremos
nuestros compromisos como tal
el compromiso del artículo 5 la
vicepresidenta de harris va a
encontrarse con esos aliados en rumanía
y en polonia al final de esta semana ha
dejado claro que los estados unidos
compartieran de la responsabilidad del
cuidado de los refugiados para que los
costos no caigan enteramente sobre los
países europeos en la frontera con
ucrania ayer hablé con mis contrapartes
en francia alemania y el reino unido
sobre la mayor violencia de roses
ucrania y los pasos que vamos a tomar
juntos con nuestros aliados y socios en
todo el mundo para responder a esta
agresión
estamos reforzando el mayor paquete de
sanciones en la historia y eso está
causando un gran daño a la economía rusa
ha causado que
bueno la economía rusa se se desmonte el
precio del rublo ha disminuido un 50%
desde que putin anunció su guerra ahora
un rublo vale menos que un centavo
estadounidense menos que un centavo
estadounidense impedimos que el banco
central de rusia aumente el valor y lo
mantenga alto ellos no van a poder
hacerlo
sacamos a los mayores bancos rusos del
sistema financiero internacional y esto
ha limitado su capacidad de hacer
negocios con el resto del mundo
sumado a esto estamos impidiendo que
rusia acceda a semiconductores y otra
tecnología
y disminuir su fortaleza económica y
debilitar su ejército sus fuerzas
militares de aquí en años muchas
compañías están saliendo completamente
de rusia sin que se les pida durante el
fin de semana visa mastercard american
expres todas estas compañías
suspendieron servicios en rusia todas
se unen a una gran lista de compañías
globales estadounidenses de fortuna y
que apple
ha suspendido sus operaciones en rusia
la bolsa estadounidense ha detenido el
comercio de acciones rusas
el departamento de justicia de eeuu ha
ensamblado una tarea una fuerza de
tareas para perseguir
los crímenes de oligarcas rusos
nos unimos con esos aliados europeos
para tomar sus yates y sus aviones sus
apartamentos todas sus ganancias para
asegurarnos de que compartan el dolor de
esta guerra de putin son yates gigantes
de ustedes lo han visto en la prensa
algunos he leído que uno era más de 400
pies
cuestan miles de minutos de abc la
decisión
tiene un costo aquí en casa la guerra de
puntilla está yendo en las bombas de
gasolina las familias colombianas desde
que empezó el incremento militar ruso en
las fronteras el precio de la gasolina
aumentó 75 centavos en eeuu y con esta
acción va a aumentar más voy a hacer
todo lo posible para minimizar el precio
de esta guerra aquí en casa en
coordinación con nuestros socios ya
hemos anunciado que vamos a liberar 60
millones de barriles de petróleo de
nuestras reservas conjuntas la mitad
330 millones viene de los estados unidos
y estamos tomando pasos para asegurarnos
que haya un suministro confiable de
energía
seguiremos trabajando con todas estas
herramientas para poder proteger
negocios y familias estadounidenses
quiero decir esto
las compañías de petróleo y gas las
firmas financieras que los respaldan
entendemos la guerra de putin en contra
del pueblo ucraniano tenemos que estar
causando altos precios eso es claro y
evidente pero
no es ninguna excusa
para ejercer unos grandes incrementos o
cualquier esfuerzo para disfrutar esta
situación
oa los consumidores estadounidenses la
agresión rusa nos está costando a todos
y no es momento de buscar ganancias
quiero ser claro sobre lo que no vamos a
tolerar
pero también quiero reconocer aquellas
firmas en la industria que están
saliendo de rusia y se unen a otros
negocios que están liderando con el
ejemplo es el momento de hacer nuestra
parte asegurarnos que lo estamos tomando
ventaja déjenme ser claro
sobre otros dos puntos en primer lugar
no es cierto que mi administración mis
políticas estén impidiendo la producción
energética doméstica eso no es cierto
incluso en medio de la pandemia las
compañías de eeuu han sacado más
petróleo durante mi primer año en el
cargo que durante el primer año de
predecesor estamos aproximándonos a
producciones récord de gas y de petróleo
y estamos en camino a romper ese récord
el próximo año en eeuu 90%
de la producción petrolífera está en
tierra que no es propiedad del gobierno
federal y el resto del 10% que ocurre en
tierra federal la industria tiene
millones de hectáreas hay 900 permisos y
podrían estar excavando mañana la semana
pasada del año pasado hay 900 el sur
nueve mil permisos que ya están
aprobados déjenme ser claro
no están utilizándolos para producción
en estos momentos esa es la decisión y
estos son los hechos tenemos que ser
honestos con los hechos en segundo lugar
esta crisis es un recordatorio de que
para proteger la economía a largo plazo
tenemos que ser independientes en
energía he tenido muchas conversaciones
con nuestros aliados europeos sobre cómo
deberían liberarse del petróleo ruso
esto no es sostenible
debería motivarnos a acelerar la
transición de la energía limpia es una
perspectiva que
nuestros aliados europeos y nosotros
compartimos en un futuro en el que ambos
podamos crear una mayor independencia
no vamos
disminuir los precios de energía a
través de desmontar las protecciones al
medio ambiente pero con autos eléctricos
con créditos fiscales que pueden ayudar
a las familias a utilizar energía limpia
eso va a ayudar
y si lo hacemos si sabemos que lo
hacemos significa que nadie tiene que
pensar en el precio de la gasolina en el
futuro
eso significará que tiranos como putty
no podrán utilizar combustibles fósiles
como armas en contra otras naciones y
hará que eeuu sea un líder mundial en
manufactura y exportación de energía
limpia y tecnología de energía limpia en
el futuro a países de todo el mundo esa
es la meta que deberíamos buscar durante
las últimas semanas el pueblo ucraniano
ha inspirado el mundo y hablo en sentido
literal inspirado el mundo con su coraje
con su patriotismo con su determinación
a vivir libres la guerra de putin
ha causado un gran sufrimiento y una
perdida necesaria de vida sobre mujeres
niños cualquier en ucrania tanto ucrania
a tu cráneos como rusos los dirían su
craneanos así como las vides del resto
del mundo han pedido un cese al fuego
reiteradamente para el indio humanitario
para que haya una diplomacia verdadera
pero putin está determinado a seguir en
su camino sangriento sin importar el
costo
putin ahora está atacando ciudades está
atacando hospitales civiles apartamentos
la semana pasada atacó la mayor planta
nuclear de europa
sin ningún cuidadoso por una posible
derrame nuclear
hay ahora más o menos 2 millones de
ucranianos como refugiados rusia sigue
aumentando su avance a un precio
horrible pero esto es claro
ucrania nunca será una victoria para
putin putin puede tomar una ciudad pero
nunca podrá tener todo el país y si no
respondemos al asalto de putin sobre la
paz y estabilidad global y el costo de
la libertad
el costo al pueblo estadunidense ya la
libertad va a ser mayor tenemos que
seguir respaldando al pueblo ucraniano
mientras lucha por su país le pido al
congreso que apruebe
el paquete de asistencia de 12 mil
millones dólares que ha estado pidiendo
el pueblo ucraniano está demostrando con
coraje físico que no van a permitir que
putin tome lo que quiere eso es claro
van a defender su libertad su democracia
sus vidas y vamos a seguir brindando
asistencia de seguridad asistencia
económica y humanitaria
vamos a respaldarlo en contra de la
tiranía la opresión
los actos violentos de subyugación
que la gente en todas partes de pronto
les ha sorprendido
en todas partes se está hablando de la
libertad
cuando la historia de esta guerra es
escrita la guerra de putin sobre ucrania
va a dejar una ruta mucho más débil y
aún resto del mundo mucho más fuerte que
dios bendiga a todas estas personas en
ucrania ahora me voy para texas muchas
gracias sé que hay muchas preguntas
y
sé que hay muchas preguntas
pero hay mucho más que es necesario
dejar claro voy a quedarme en este
momento aquí